MALE SPEAKER: Well good
morning and welcome to Authors
at Google in Cambridge, Mass.
Today it's my enormous pleasure
to introduce Joel Christian
Gill.
And before I launch into the
prepared portion of my remarks,
I have to say that Joel is
the first author we've ever
had in Cambridge whom
I've spotted actually
selling a copy of his book
on the way to the talk.
The security guard
downstairs bought a copy.
Well done, Joel.
He's staying for lunch.
Please feel free to join us.
The cafeteria staff may
each get a copy too.
Who knows?
I don't know.
Nobody is safe, clearly.
Anyway, more formally,
Joel is the Associate Dean
of Student Affairs of New
Hampshire Institute of Art.
And he is a member of the
Boston Comics Roundtable.
He received his
Master in Fine Arts
from Boston University and
a BA from Roanoke College.
He's here today to
discuss his provocatively
titled and amazing graphic
anthology, "Strange Fruit,
Volume One: Uncelebrated
Narratives from Black History."
He has uncovered and
retells in dramatic fashion
nine stories of extraordinary
African Americans
whose lives have been
long forgotten by most.
I was excited to learn about
these strong individuals,
and I know you will be too.
Please join me in welcoming
Joel Christian Gill.
JOEL CHRISTIAN GILL: That
makes me sound so much more
impressive, to hear
someone else talk about me.
Well thank you guys
for having me down.
I appreciate the
opportunity to come down
and talk to you about my work.
I'm going to talk about a
few things this morning.
I'm going to talk
specifically about how
I came to the idea of calling
my book Strange Fruit,
and what the inspiration
for that was.
Because that seems to be
a really common question
that people ask me.
Why did you title your
book "Strange Fruit"?
I'm going to talk
to you how I came up
with the stories
for "Strange Fruit"
because you all have the book.
As you can see,
some of these things
are very obscure,
very-- sort of-- you
have to find them in a
lot of different places.
And then I'm going
to talk to you
specifically about
how I make the comic.
And then I'm going
to read and show you
on the screen one of the
stories, my favorite story
in "Strange Fruit,"
which is called
"Two Letters" about a
slave name Spotswood Rice.
I went to college
initially to draw comics.
And in southwestern
Virginia where I'm from,
there weren't any
illustration programs.
And so I went into a
graphic design program.
And my second semester in,
I took a painting class.
And if you've ever
taken a painting class
and been artistically
inclined, you
know that it's like a
puzzle you can't solve.
And so you go down
that rabbit hole,
trying to figure out how to
solve that problem of painting.
And one of the
most common issues
with painters-- with anybody
who makes any type of art--
is how you get your inspiration.
Like, where does it come from?
And at the time,
I had a professor
whose name was Brian Sieveking.
He was my drawing teacher
and he was really brilliant.
And he did these paintings
of southern rock stars,
or sideshow freaks.
You know, like the Incredible
Half boy, or the Human Trunk.
So I remember
thinking to myself,
why do you paint the
things that you do?
They just all seem
really disconnected.
And he said, well
I collect folk art.
And when I was in
college, I had gone
through this process
of trying to make
these paintings about
how bad Nicaragua was.
And how messed up the
situation in Nicaragua was.
And at the same time,
I met Howard Finster,
who was a pretty
famous folk artist.
If you guys have ever seen REM's
cover, the lead singer of REM
is actually sitting in this rock
garden, Howard Finster's rock
garden in Georgia.
He said, I met Howard Finster.
And Howard Finster paints
these amazing things.
He paints Elvis as a baby.
Or he paints Henry Ford's wife.
Or he paints this
amazing painting
called, "The Path to Hell is
Paved With Good Intentions."
And he said, I met
Howard Finster,
and I realized that because
he's a folk artist-- which
are these people who are
sort of outside artists,
they didn't go to college,
and they start painting
in their 60s-- he
said, he had this one
hand in cable television.
And he had the other
hand in the church.
And so he had these
two conflicting things
that were happening to him.
So he was painting the things
that were interesting to him.
And he said, so I looked back
at those paintings in Nicaragua,
and I was like, I don't
really care about Nicaragua.
I mean, yeah, it's bad, but
I don't really care about it.
And at the same time, he
was writing these things
about Ty Cobb.
And he's a really big
baseball historian.
So he said, I did these
paintings of Ty Cobb.
And everybody thought these
paintings were much better.
And the difference between
those paintings of Ty Cobb
and the paintings that
I was doing before,
is that these are something
that I'm interested in.
And so I immediately
thought to myself,
that's what I'm going to do.
I'm going to find something
that I'm interested in,
and I'm going to
do paintings of it.
About that same time,
there was an article
in the paper in Roanoke,
Virginia, where I'm from.
Roanoke is a small city.
I live right outside of
Manchester, New Hampshire now.
Manchester's really small.
And so it's about the same size.
So there was an
article in the Roanoke
Times about a tree
that had fallen.
Typically trees falling
is not a news event, even
in a small city.
But this tree was supposed
to have been cursed.
And the article
was about the curse
of this tree falling
because it was
the centerpiece
of a lynching that
happened in Roanoke,
Virginia in 1893.
So I wanted to
know more about it.
So I went back and looked
at some of the images
in the newspaper
about the lynchings.
And this is from the
Roanoke Daily Record.
If you can see the very
top left hand corner,
it says, Negroes Lynched.
There was a woman, a farmer, who
was going into Roanoke to sell
her wares at the farmer's
market, which is not
unlike Quincy Market, you know,
Faneuil Hall sort of place.
She was selling grapes.
And while she was
selling the grapes,
a man approached her and asked
her how much the grapes were.
And she said, $0.60.
He told her, he said,
well I'll give you
more of those if you
actually deliver them.
So she agreed.
And then she followed him.
So she followed him
down an alleyway.
And he got to a place
where there was a gate.
Once he got her
through the gate,
he shut the gate behind
him and pulled out a razor,
and said to give me your money.
So she proceeded to give him her
purse, which had $2.00 in it.
And she begged for her life.
And she begged and pleaded
for him not to kill her.
And he immediately grabbed her
and tried to slit her throat.
Well, she fought him off.
And when she fought him off,
she knocked the razor out
of his hand.
But in the struggle, he
was able to grab a brick
and he beat her until she was
unconscious with the brick,
and left her there
in a pool of blood.
She was found later
by the authorities.
And they took her to
the local hospital.
And because this happened
near a black neighborhood,
the police went to
a black neighborhood
looking for a suspect.
This was before she had given
a description or anything.
So they found a
man named Thomas.
And they brought
Thomas to the hospital.
And in her fugue, they asked
her if she could identify Thomas
as the guy who had beat
her in this alleyway.
And she said she couldn't be
sure, but show me his hat.
If you show me his
hat, I can be sure.
So they showed her the hat,
and she said that's him.
Thomas was taken to jail.
And he was locked
up in the jail.
Now at the time, Roanoke
was a stop on the railroad.
And there was all
these railroad riders
who had stopped in
Roanoke, and they were all
hanging out in these bars
by the railroad tracks.
Somehow it got to them that
this horrible thing had happened
to this woman, and that it was
a black man that had done it.
And like most mobs in a drunken
fugue, they went to the jail.
And the sheriff was
able to deter them.
He came out, sort
of talked them down,
had a conversation with them.
And they dispersed.
Well, they were not
to be turned away.
In the meantime, the mayor
got together with the sheriff
and said, we need
to do something
to keep these people out.
So they called in
the local militia
to protect the prison, the jail.
So the militia
surrounded the jail.
And the mob came back.
When the mob came
back, they were larger,
they were more
menacing, and they
were trying to attack the jail.
Something happened, and the
militia fired on the crowd.
And they killed nine people.
When the dust cleared, that
only made the people madder.
You would think it would
make them disperse,
but it would make them madder.
So they regrouped.
And in the meantime, the mayor
and the sheriff got together,
and they were going to send
Thomas to Lynchburg, Virginia
to get him away from the mob.
So they put him on
a cart, and they
started taking him to Lynchburg.
He got about five
miles out of Lynchburg
when the mob caught up with him.
And they wrapped the rope
around his neck and they drug
him back to Roanoke.
They drug him through
the street, people
shooting at him the entire time,
and they hung him in a tree.
They shot him more.
They placed a sign on the
front, said do not remove,
by order of Judge Lynch.
And a sign on the back, because
they were mad at the mayor,
that this is the mayor's friend.
So in those three days, he
just hung there, his body.
And people would go by
and they would actually
strip pieces of clothing,
even pieces of his skin
off as souvenirs.
This happened for
a couple of days,
and at the end of
the three days,
the coroner came with
a number of officials,
and they were going to
pull this body down.
And at the time, they
came to the conclusion
that he was killed
by unknown people
under unknown circumstances.
And so as they take him down--
they're going to go bury him--
another mob shows back up.
This mob, just as
enraged as the first mob,
they're going to take
his body and bury it
at the mayor's house.
A prominent minister
had been out of town.
When he heard about
this, he decided
to come in to be the cooler
head and talk them out of it.
So instead of burying this body
of this man-- who, by the way,
had not been convicted,
hadn't been proven innocent,
hadn't been proven
guilty, no one
knew it was all about a hat.
They put him in
a railroad wagon.
They piled him up with lumber.
And then they poured coal
oil on his body and drug
it down and paraded
it through town,
down to the river, where they
actually lit this body on fire
and burned it over
the course of a day.
And people came out
and had picnics,
they brought their children.
Sort of like, this is what
happens when you do something.
So I read about this
in the newspaper.
And so I thought, this is
something I'm interested in.
So I decided to do some
paintings based on those,
with no fixed understanding
about what the paintings would
be about, they were just
paintings about lynching.
So I was working at
Kinko's at the time.
So I would sit at Kinko's
until 3:00 or 4:00 o'clock
in the morning, and I
would draw and print out
these lynching images.
After about a week of doing
this, as you can probably
imagine, I was disturbed
and thought to myself,
I can't do this.
This not something
that I can do.
So I stopped doing it and
just put it aside, always
in the back of my mind.
In the meantime, I moved
from southwestern Virginia
to Boston to go to
BU for grad school.
My wife moved our
four kids to BU
so that I could
go to grad school.
And just to recap about
that town I grew up in,
southwestern Virginia
is beautiful,
if you ever get a
chance to go and see.
Roanoke is called the
star city of the South.
It's an amazing city.
If you know anybody who's ever
hiked the Appalachian Trail,
that's where they end
up in some places.
People stop along the way.
And I'm actually from
a little smaller town
outside called Rocky Mount.
Which its claim to fame is the
moonshine capital of the world.
When I was in third
grade, there was
a Klan march in Rocky Mount.
This was about 1983.
Now I grew up in the
projects in this small town.
And I was never
afraid to go anywhere.
Me and my friends,
we didn't have money.
So we had bikes.
And so that was
our entertainment.
We would ride our bikes
places, sit in apple trees
and eat people's
apples and cherries,
and never was afraid
to go anywhere.
So I move in to Boston.
So that was a
culture shock to me,
because now the
black people were
speaking a different language.
Which was odd to me, because
all the black people in Virginia
spoke English.
I'd been here for
about two weeks
and I took a trip to the MFA
with the painting class at BU.
And they had this thing called
the Brandt Collection, which
was a collection of modern art
that was separate from the MFA.
So we got in for
free, but you had
to pay to get into
this other thing.
And there were two
security guards there,
and they were black.
And one of them heard
my southern accent,
and he was just like,
hey, you from the South?
I was stationed in
the South, and I
dated this woman in the South.
And he started talking to me
and sort of being my friend.
And I asked him how much it
was to get into the Brandt
Collection, and he said
it's free, go ahead.
Go on in.
So let me into the
Brandt Collection,
and I walked around,
and I came out.
And then he started
talking, asking me
how long I'd been in Boston,
what I thought of the city
so far.
He asked me if I
was into sports.
And I said, I'm not
really into sports.
I live about four
blocks from Fenway,
but I really like basketball.
He said, you close to Fenway?
I'm like, yeah.
He's like, I was born
and raised in Boston.
But I'll never roof
for the Red Sox.
I'm a Yankees fan.
And now I hadn't
been in Boston long,
but I knew that if you were
a Yankees fan in Boston,
that was kind of like being
a prostitute in church.
Like, you're sweating.
Or Mike Tyson at a
spelling bee, or something.
It was like-- it was
something you didn't do.
So I was like, how do
you become a Yankees fan
if you live in Boston?
He said, the Red Sox are
a racist organization
historically.
And he pulled out
this laminated article
that he'd been
carrying around that
was written by this
sportswriter in Worcester
about Boston and race.
And one of the things he
said in there was Boston
has two sports legends
in its history.
They have Ted Williams
and Bill Russell.
Ted Williams never won anything.
Bill Russell won
11 championships,
and who do they name
the tunnel after?
And I was like, wow.
I had never thought of that.
He said that the
manager of the Red Sox
passed on every black
player, including
Hank Aaron, because he
said he wasn't going
to sit around waiting
for some nigger.
And I was like, I didn't know--
that was common in Virginia,
like, that's the kind of
thing you just knew about.
But I was coming to the
bastion of liberalism.
Like that was miles from where
abolitionists ran newspapers.
So I was sort of
shocked by that.
So I left there with
this new world view.
I lived in BU
housing, and there was
a guy who lived on
the bottom floor who
was a business
journalist professor.
And he also did business
journalism on CNBC.
He had bright red hair.
I can't remember his name.
But we only called
him by his last name.
And he was a great guy.
And he stopped me one day in the
hallway when I was coming up,
and he goes, Joel, where are all
of the black people in Boston?
And I said, what?
He said, I haven't seen black
people since I've been here.
I don't see that
many black people.
He was from DC.
He said, there are a lot
of black people in DC.
He said, there's not
that many black people.
Have you noticed?
Actually, I hadn't noticed.
I hadn't even looked
up-- because I
was working on my MFA--
to take the opportunity
to notice that there wasn't
that many black people.
I'm like, that's kind of odd.
He was like, Yeah,
it's really odd.
There's not a lot
of black people.
This is not something
I'm used to.
This was a white Irish
guy with bright red hair.
I was like, I hadn't
thought about that.
The end of that first
year, I had to get a job.
My wife was like,
you got to work.
Get a job.
Work as hard as you can.
We're living in Boston.
You can't just go to
school and not work.
So I went down to Faneuil Hall
to get a job waiting tables.
In the meantime, I saw a
caricature artist booth.
And I'm like, no I'm
not gonna get a job.
I'm gonna get a job at the
caricature artist booth.
That's what I'm going to do.
Because I can do that.
Waiting tables, I
mean I can make money.
But I can make more money at
this caricature artist booth
then I ever would
waiting tables.
So I got a job at the
caricature artist booth .
And I spent Friday,
Saturday, and Sunday
in Faneuil Hall
drawing caricatures.
Which is a great job, if you're
young and want to do that.
Because you get to talk
to hundreds of people.
You make tips.
And you get to basically
hang out in Faneuil Hall
all weekend, which is great.
So I was hanging out at Faneuil
Hall, and this guy shows up.
He was about my age.
And he was black and his
girlfriend was white.
And he was talking
to his girlfriend
about where they
were going to eat.
And he was suggesting they eat
inside Faneuil Hall, Quincy
Marketplace.
You know, I joke with people--
and I was talking to him.
And I'm like, if you take that
girl inside Quincy Marketplace,
that's a sleep on the
couch kind of dinner.
Because you're basically
eating fast food.
There's a place over
on the north end
that a friend of
mine and I ate when
I came to Boston a
couple of years ago.
Maybe you should go over there.
He said, I'm not
going over there.
Not at night.
Not with her.
I said, really?
He goes, oh yeah.
And by the way, don't
go to south Boston.
Don't go to this neighborhood.
Don't go to that neighborhood.
I said, really?
He's like, yeah, they
don't like our kind there.
Now remember, there was
a Klan march in my town
when I was in third grade.
Like a declaration that we
don't like black people.
And here I was in this place
where there were abolitionists,
where the Kennedys came from,
where all these people who
were civil rights pioneers were
supposed to have come from.
And now people are telling
me not to go to these places.
The last thing that
happened to me in Boston,
which was really
rather traumatic--
psychologically traumatic, was
I was walking home from BU one
night.
My studio was on 808
Commonwealth Ave.
And so I walked down St Mary's
to get to my apartment, which
was only like a couple blocks.
It was about 3:00
in the morning.
And I had gotten
to this place where
I would wear these
giant headphones.
Now you would think
because of the way
I looked-- I had a hoodie on,
I had giant headphones on,
and I had a giant jacket on,
and sneakers, that I would
be listening to rap
music, but I was probably
listening to an audio book.
Or something as benign as that.
Not to say that
rap music doesn't
come through those
headphones, It
was just that usually
it's just an audio book.
And I was walking along there,
it's like 3:00 in the morning.
And a police officer was
flying around that corner.
And when he saw me, he
slowed almost to a stop.
And when he did
that, I immediately
understood why people
run, because I had not
done anything.
And it was just about the
way I looked that he stopped.
He went, but I was terrified.
After that I graduated from BU.
We went back to Virginia.
Nothing ever bad happened to me
other than that cop stopping,
and people telling me
things when I was in Boston.
But as a dad with a family,
I had four kids and living
in Boston.
Boston's a great city if
you're under 30 and no kids.
If you're over 30 and kids,
it's like a nightmare.
So my wife and I were
like, we are Southerners.
We had just decided.
We were Southerners.
We are going back to the South.
It's going to be great.
But there was also
this understanding
that being a black man and
being in love with the South
is a very complicated thing.
It reminded me of
something that I
read in the autobiography
of Malcolm X
where he said, at least in
the South, they'll tell you
they don't want
to sit beside you.
And there was another thing
that Dick Gregory-- who
was a social commentator,
comedian, and civil rights
activist-- said
that in the South,
they don't care
how big you get, as
long as you don't get too close.
And in the North, they don't
care how close you get,
as long as you
don't get too big.
Those two things sort
of weighed on me.
Plus my experiences of
coming to the South,
and I'm coming to
Boston and hearing
about the riots in the '70s, the
bussing, and then these things
about the racist organizations,
and the Ted Williams tunnel
not being Bill Russells tunnel.
Because that would
make sense really.
It would make sense if it
was the Bill Russells tunnel.
And I started thinking about
those lynching paintings again.
But I was thinking about them
in a different context now.
Because I had spent a
whole long time listening
to "Strange Fruit" by
Billie Holiday's collection.
And "Strange Fruit" and
how I had done something
that a lot of my ancestors--
just to quote Maya Angelou--
I am the hope and
the dream of a slave.
I'd already done something that
a lot of people, even my peers,
because most of the people that
I grew up with were in prison.
So I had done something
my peers hadn't done.
So I had come a long way.
And so I started to reevaluate
those lynching paintings
in a way that I was
talking about sort
of making social commentary as
a metaphor for how far we've
come, but how far
we still have to go.
And so I did a series of
paintings based on lynchings,
and I called the
show, "Strange Fruit."
And the most
successful painting was
this one, called "Strange Fruit
Harvested: He Cut the Rope."
In this painting, I was
trying to talk about, and make
commentary about, how
far I was able to come.
Because I'm no longer
hanging from that tree.
I had cut the tree, but
the rope was still there.
So it was sort of
a metaphor to say,
we've become a really
long way, but we still
haven't come far enough.
So a friend of mine
came to that show--
a guy I went to BU with,
who lived two hours from me
in Virginia-- and he moved back
a year after I did, and came
to the show, which
was a big deal.
And people came to
the show and said
it was beautiful and
disturbing, beautiful
and ugly at the same time.
And he looked at the
whole show and he said,
it seems to me
like your paintings
are trying to tell a story.
And they're failing.
And he was absolutely right.
Because one of the things you
learn about art in grad school,
is when you get out,
nobody tells you
when you've done anything wrong.
Your mom always says that
everything you make is great.
No matter what you
make, she's going
to pin it to the refrigerator.
And so, that was an
eye opener for me.
Because he was absolutely right.
The paintings were
trying to tell a story,
and they were failing.
And this was the most successful
one of the entire bunch.
So that started to
prompt me into thinking
about storytelling again,
and how I could specifically
use visual media to
tell the stories.
So that made me come full
circle to drawing comics again.
And so I started thinking about
ways in which to tell my story,
like living in the South,
coming from the projects,
being in this position that I'd
been in, and being a success.
Because at this time I was
teaching at a small college,
I was running a gallery.
I was successful by
all measures of what
I was supposed to be doing.
So I started thinking about ways
in which to tell that story.
So I started this comic
called Dandelions.
And it was this long epic
autobiographical metaphor
of me and my life, and I
got about 50 pages into it,
and a friend of mine-- so I
got another harsh critique.
By this time I had
moved back to Boston
and I was going to the
Boston Comics Roundtable
at this point.
And I took it to the
Boston Comics Roundtable
for a critique.
And a guy who I'm friends
with now was going through it,
and he got about 30 pages in,
and he looks at me and he goes,
I don't know what's going on.
I'm 30 pages into this and
there's nothing happening.
So I'm like, I'm failing again.
I'm absolutely failing again.
So I started looking at
people who made comics
to try to figure out how I
could tell these stories that I
was trying to tell.
These vaguely social
conscious stories
that have uplifting
elements to them.
How can I tell these stories?
And I was cyberstalking.
Have you ever heard
of a library degree?
If you get a
library degree, it's
like you don't have
a degree in it,
but you go and read every book
on it that you possibly can.
If you have a library card,
you can get a degree in it.
So I was trying to get a
library degree in comics.
So I would look up artists,
then I would look up their work.
Then I would cyberstalk them for
a while, looking at their work
online, trying to get as much
information as I possibly can.
And I ran into this
cartoonist named Box Brown.
Box Brown has a book
out right now called
"Andre the Giant,"
which is really great.
And so when I
Googled Box Brown, I
came up with the story
of Henry Box Brown.
Henry Box Brown was a slave
who was born in Virginia,
and got together with
some abolitionists
after an issue that he had had
with his master and his family
being sold, and mailed
himself in a box from Virginia
to Philadelphia.
And so I didn't know
much about Box Brown,
but I knew a couple of things--
that he was in Philadelphia,
he was a white kid, and he
didn't get there in a box.
So I sent him an email.
And I said, I'm just
curious as to why
you have the same name is this
slave named Henry Box Brown.
And he said, well I'm
just square shaped,
so my friends call me Box.
And he said, but
I've also thought
about doing a comic about
this guy at some point.
And I sent it back to him,
because that sparked an idea.
I said, that's a fantastic idea.
I'm going to steal your idea.
And so, I stole his idea.
And I made a comic
about Henry Box Brown.
And I spent about a year
putting it together.
And I sent it to him.
And he said to me, when
I sent it back to him,
he's like, this is great.
You should do more of these.
So I put together that story.
And now I had to figure
out how to get it out.
So it wasn't a book, right?
So I couldn't shop
it to a publisher.
It was more like a one
shot kind of a thing.
And so I came to the
conclusion that I
needed to put together a
sort of series of comics.
And the series had to have
some kind of unification.
The unification was me.
But I wanted it to be the
unification to everybody else.
So I was going to go to a
convention, a comic convention,
and I was going to
sell these comics,
so I had to figure
out what to name them.
And I'm a huge Chris Ware fan.
If you're not familiar
with Chris Ware,
he won the Guardian Prize for
his book, "Jimmy Corrigan:
The Smartest Kid on Earth."
He's the only
cartoonist to ever be
included in the
Whitney Biennial.
He's brilliant.
His work is amazing.
It's slow and
methodical, but it's
like-- it's kind of like a Wes
Anderson film in a lot of ways.
It's quirky, and it's deeper
than it looks like it is.
So Chris Ware has this series
called "Acme Novelty Library."
And in "Acme
Novelty Library," he
does one story in each
comic, but they're
connected to other stories.
So maybe 18 will
be "Rusty Brown."
And then 19 will be
"Building Stories."
Then once he gets the
entire thing together,
he collects them separately,
and then puts out a book.
His latest is called
"Building Stories."
And it was all serialized
in "Acme Novelty Library."
So I thought to myself, what
could be my "Acme Novelty
Library"?
So I started thinking about
a unifying theme or idea.
And I went back to
"Strange Fruit,"
because if you think
about Henry Box Brown,
Henry Box Brown cut the rope.
Right?
He did that thing
that I did in a time
when it was harder
to actually do that.
And so I thought to
myself, I'm going
to name my comic
"Strange Fruit."
So I put together
"Strange Fruit,"
and started selling them
with different comic covers.
And each one had
a different story.
So when I went to the
first one, the first one
is the top left hand corner.
That was the first
one that I did.
So when I went to
the conventions,
having been a caricature
artist at Faneuil Hall,
I knew how to sell
stuff one on one.
One on one retail is
something I'm good at.
If you could get
a degree in that,
I would have a
degree in 101 Retail.
Friends of mine say
I could sell ice
to people who have a glass
of ice water in their hand.
So I would sell these comics.
And I would sell hundreds
of them at a show.
While I was selling the comics,
people would come up to me
and they would say, have you
heard about Marshall Taylor?
And I'm like, no.
Who's Marshall Taylor?
And they would say,
Marshall Taylor
was the first black
world champion
in any sport in America.
And he was a cyclist.
And at one point he held seven
world records in cycling.
And I'm like, really?
I would pull out my
little book and I
would write down
Marshall Taylor.
And then I would go look him up.
And then I would do a story
about Marshall Taylor.
People would tell me, have you
heard of Theofilus Thompson?
And I'm like, no, I haven't
heard of Theofilus Thompson,
why don't you tell me more?
So I would write down
Theofilus Thompson's name.
And they would all be subsequent
issues of "Strange Fruit."
Each one of them was a separate
cover and a separate story.
"Strange Fruit"
would have one story
about some obscure
black history,
and then another story would
have sketch book images.
In one of my favorite
covers for "Strange Fruit"
I put myself as a toy.
This is all digital.
That toy does not exist.
It's all built in Photoshop.
And I did one where I put
myself on the cover of "Amazing
Fantasy Number 15."
And this is the one with
Theofilus Thompson in it.
So Fulcrum approached me about
halfway through and asked me
if I would be interested
in putting together
all of my stories
as an anthology.
And I had already
shopped this to a number
of publishing companies.
And they said things like,
put together a new book.
You're a first time author.
Can you do it in
black and white?
We can do it.
People don't buy anthologies.
Those kind of things.
And so I was resigned to
actually just continue
to do what-- I mean, I work
at a college, so I had a job.
So I didn't need to
make money with the art.
So I was going to continue
to do what I had been doing.
When Fulcrum
approached me and said
we should put
these all together.
And do you have more
of these stories?
And I said yes,
as I got my book.
Of course I have more stories.
And I start to list off
some of those stories.
And they were like, great.
We can put this all
together, and we'll just
go with the title
"Strange Fruit,"
because that's what
these stories are.
And so I started to
work on those stories.
And in the process
of doing that,
we talked about who could
write the forward for the book.
And the first person I thought
was Henry Louis Gates, Jr.,
because one of the stories
in "Strange Fruit," the story
of Richard Potter who was the
first American stage magician.
And also a black man
from New Hampshire.
I don't know if you've
been to New Hampshire,
but when I left this
morning, I significantly
decreased the black population
by leaving the state.
So you can imagine what it
was like for Richard Potter
in the early 1800s, late 1700s
when he was a magician up
and down the east coast,
living in New Hampshire.
But the first time I heard about
that was Henry Louis Gates, Jr.
was talking about him on NPR.
And I was like,
that's another person
I can write down and go look up.
And so I thought
he would be great.
Plus I used his encyclopedia
of African American History.
So we were able to
get in touch with him,
through Facebook of all places.
And he wrote the story
without any prompting from us.
He defended the
title "Strange Fruit"
automatically in his writing.
Like, this is no longer
about black bodies dangling,
this is about stories
that are dangling
outside the
mainstream of history.
Which was pretty amazing to
have someone of his caliber
write that about me.
So now that you
have some background
about how "Strange Fruit" and
how the stories came about,
I want to talk to you
a little bit about how
I went about making the stories.
For the most part, I
did everything analog.
So it was pencil and paper.
I would do the thumbnails
in my sketch book.
And then I would transfer
those to Bristol board.
Do blue line images of
them, and then ink them.
Then I would scan them.
And then if they
were 18 by 24, I
would have to repiece
those images back together.
Well, I couldn't
do that anymore.
I had to go digitally.
And so I started doing
everything digitally.
With Wacom tablets
and everything.
So now everything is
completely digital.
And I'm going to talk to you
about that with "Two Letters."
Now "Spotswood
Rice" is the story
about a slave-- we have a
couple of documents about him.
We have two letters
that he wrote,
and then we have
all the information
about him being in the military.
The two letters he wrote, he
wrote a letter to his children
saying that don't
worry about life.
It's going to be OK and I'm
going to come and get you.
And then he wrote a letter
to his slave master,
his former slave master
after he had run away.
And he said, I'm coming
to get my children.
And I'm bringing an army
of 1,000 black men with me.
And there's an interview
with his daughter in 1925,
where she talks about
living with Spotswood Rice.
So the connection that
I was able to make
is that he actually came
back and got his daughter.
And so I wanted to
tell this story,
but I didn't want
to use my words.
I wanted to use the words
that he wrote initially.
So I wanted to mimic
his handwriting.
And I wanted to actually use
the words in his letters.
And there are images
of his letters.
Here's the image of the letter
to Miss Kitty Diggs, who
was his former slave master.
And this is actually him.
So once I got the
images down, and I
knew that I wanted
to use the words,
I wanted to know what Spotswood
Rice would actually look like.
And there's no images of him.
And so I started
doing some drawings
where I sort of imagined
him as a big man.
Because he went
into the military.
And he was about taking
care of his children.
And when you read his letters,
he feels like a big man
when you read him.
He feels like a man who's that
pen is too small in his hand.
And so after I got that,
I went through the process
of deciding how
to do the comics.
These are thumbnails.
And thumbnails and comics
really are hieroglyphics.
They only make sense to me.
One of the things I
knew I wanted to do
was, I didn't want
to use any words.
And so I had to have places
where there were exclamations
and there were racial
slurs in the words.
And so I decided to
use colors and symbols.
So the colors I used are
yellow, orange, and red
as mounting anger.
And the symbols, we'll
get to those in a second.
So the symbols here
I wanted to use,
the derogatory term
for black people, coon.
I wanted to use that one.
And I wanted that word to
be a picture, so that it
was embedded with all the
information as opposed
to me saying the word.
If you've watched
"Django" for example,
the n-word becomes
wallpaper in that movie.
He says it so much
that you can actually
forget that he's actually
saying it anymore.
And so I wanted you not to
forget that it was there.
I didn't want it to be passive.
I didn't want it to
be n-- dot, dot, dot.
I wanted it to be
something else.
And so I tended to
use actual images--
racist images-- in order to
show what those words are so
that there's a disconnect
between the person
and the word.
So that you see that disconnect.
So I decided that
in this instance
I was going to use the
actual image of a coon.
So once I get the
actual thumbnail,
I do a larger thumbnail
in my sketch book
where I start to map out things.
Once this process is done,
I scan this image-- well
actually, what I did
was I went back through
and I wrote out the
entire letters, trying
to mimic as close
to his handwriting.
But I wanted it to be legible.
And also the thing
I wanted it to be,
was I wanted all of the
misspellings to be in there.
So that the misspellings
are specifically his.
So these are his
words, not mine.
There's no real
evidence about what
Spotswood Rice was able to do.
Or what he did.
So all that's
conjecture on my part,
but the words are actually true.
And we know he did
eventually get his daughter.
So once I got the words, and
once I got the thumbnail,
I scan this in and I did a
drawing over it in Photoshop.
And I put those things
on three layers.
So I put the ink on one layer,
and then I put the painting
on another layer,
and then I combine
those two to create
the actual image.
And so from here I want to
read to you the actual story.
And I'll show it on
the screen as well.
My children, I
take my pen in hand
to write you a few lines to let
you know I have not forgot you.
I will have you if
it costs me my life.
I want you to be contented
with whatever may be your lots,
but be assured on the 28th day,
on the 28th of the month, 800
white and 800 black soldiers
expect to start up the River
Glasgow.
And I expect to be with them.
Don't be uneasy my children.
I expect to have you.
Your Miss Kitty
Diggs, Miss Kitty
said that I tried to steal you.
God never intended for a man to
steal his own flesh and blood.
If I had any confidence
in her, I have none now.
And I want her to
remember if she meets me
with 10,000 soldiers,
she will meet her enemy.
I have no sympathy
for slave holders.
Give my love to
all, Spotswood Rice.
So here he's in encampment,
and he receives a letter.
And the letter's
from his daughter.
And again, I'm using mounting
anger with the yellow, orange,
and red.
So he starts to write
his letter back.
I received a letter
from Mary telling me
that you say I tried to
steal my child away from you.
Now I want you to
understand that Mary
is a God-given right of my own.
Hold her as long
as you can, but I
want you to remember
this one thing.
The longer you keep
my child from me,
the longer you have
to burn in hell
and the quicker
you'll get there.
Woe be to the
copperhead rabel-- which
is supposed to be rebels-- and
to the slave holding rebels,
for we are making up
about 1,000 black troops.
We don't expect to leave
them there, root nor branch.
Just hold on as long as you
can, and the worse it will be.
I once offered you, offered to
pay you $40 for my own child.
I am glad that you
did not accept.
The day that we enter Glasgow,
I want you to understand,
Kitty Diggs, my child is my own.
You call my child property.
I have no fear about getting
Mary out of your hands.
And that's how my
Daddy, Spotswood Rice
came and took me from
slavery all those years ago.
And that concludes my talk.
If you guys have
any questions, I'll
be more than happy to
answer your questions.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Are you continuing to
collect stories for the future?
JOEL CHRISTIAN GILL: Yes.
I do have for volume
two-- the funny thing that
happened when I started looking
for a second set of stories,
is that I discovered there
are uncelebrated narratives,
and then there are uncelebrated
uncelebrated narratives.
And the uncelebrated
uncelebrated narratives
are women, and people
who are disabled,
and people who are from
the queer community.
And so I started to find
stories about those people that
will be included in "Strange
Fruit, Volume Two," which
will probably be out
in about two years.
I'm doing another series called
"Tales of the Talented Tenth,"
which is from a WEB Du
Bois lecture, about 10%
to the black population
rising up and leaving
the rest of them.
And so these are more
action-based stories
about people from
obscure black history.
The first one is
about Bass Reeves,
who was the first
black US Marshall.
Or the most successful
US Marshall in history.
He caught almost 4,000
criminals over the course
of a 30-year period
in the Old West,
and no one knows about him.
Some people think he might have
been the original inspiration
for the Lone Ranger.
So I'm doing an
entire book about him.
And then after that, I'm doing
story in "Tales of the Talented
Tenth" about Bessie Stringfield.
She was a black woman
from Connecticut
who over the course of her life,
crisscrossed the United States
on a motorcycle eight times
in the '30s '40s and '50s.
She was a courier
for the US military.
They called her the
Negro motorcycle queen.
And I don't know if there's
a Caucasian motorcycle
queen, just to balance it out.
But she would call
these penny tours.
She would throw a penny at a
map, and wherever she would go,
she would just drive there.
And when she ran out of money,
she would stop and do tricks.
So she's going to
be the second one.
And then in "Strange
Fruit, Volume Two,"
which will come out after
Bessie Stringfield's "Tales
of the Talented Tenth," will
be William and Ellen Kraft
who were slaves from Louisiana.
Ellen, his wife,
could pass for white.
So on Christmas, because
the restrictions on slaves
were lightened on
Christmas day, they
contrived a plan to run away.
And she dressed as a white man.
And she put her arm
in a sling, so she
didn't have to sign anything,
because she couldn't write.
And they escaped 1,000 miles
from slavery to freedom.
I'm also going to do
Blind Tom Wiggins, who
was billed as the
last American slave.
He was an autistic savant
who was a musician.
He couldn't see.
He was blind.
But he was an amazing musician.
And he was basically sold
to a music producer who
then was able to get his
family to contract him out
until he died in the
early 20th century.
But he was billed as
the last American slave.
There was actually a famous
court case about him.
But he made amazing music.
He would also do sounds.
They would have
these shows where
they would have him come out.
And he would have
people come up and say,
you play any piece
of music and he
can mimic the music
right then and there.
So I'm doing a story about
Blind Tom Wiggins, just
to name a few.
There'll be Cathay Williams,
who was the only documented
black female Buffalo soldier.
And the only reason we
know that she actually
was a soldier in
the Union Army is
because she applied
for veteran's benefits
and was denied, even
though they know
she'd actually
fought in the war.
So those will be
some of the stories
in "Strange Fruit, Volume Two."
So I have a full plate
from here until infinity.
AUDIENCE: So one of the
things that brought me here
today is that I'm a father,
and I'm looking for things
that I can share
with my older son.
JOEL CHRISTIAN GILL: Right.
AUDIENCE: So we give
him Howard Zinn's
"Young People's History."
It's kind of a personal
question that you
can deal with how you like.
But you have four
kids, you said.
JOEL CHRISTIAN GILL: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: How do
you talk to them?
How do they understand
this history
that you're talking about?
Like these stories are for
the most part triumphant,
they're about exceptional
circumstances.
But the content
there is horrifying.
So what's that like?
JOEL CHRISTIAN GILL:
There's two things.
My wife is white.
So my children have no
real concept of race
at all, which is
really interesting.
And when talking to my
son about this one time--
we were having this
conversation, and I was like,
you've never been
in a fight, right?
And he was like, nope.
Never been in a fight.
And at first I'm like, man,
he's gotta learn how to fight.
I gotta get him
into this situation.
And I'm like, wait a minute.
I worked damn hard so
he'd never have to fight.
He'd never have to
worry about this stuff.
And my kids have no concept
of the things that--
like any of the issues
that I'm talking about.
When people actually
raise it to them,
it seems like it's just
going over their head.
And so to get them
to understand that,
I talk to them about this stuff.
I sort of make these
things amazing.
Like, look at this amazing
thing that happened.
And like any kid whose
parent does something that's
interesting to
most other people,
they've been living
with it all their life,
so-- I have a
Wacom tablet that's
about this big,
that's at my house.
It's in the living room, and
I draw on it all the time.
If my kids' friends
come over, they
stand behind me the whole time.
And my son is like, I have air
soft guns, let's go outside.
And they're like, no,
this is really cool.
So my kids have no
real concept of it.
It's sort of like to give them
an awareness of those things
and to talk to them about it.
My son, who was eight
or nine when I started.
He's 12 now.
So he's read all the stories.
And he understands them, and
he thinks they're really cool.
But he has a clear
understanding about that.
And I try to make sure
that he understands
those type of things.
But they are so
sheltered in comparison
to what I was, that
they don't even see it.
Which I'm OK with.
I'm absolutely OK
with my kids not ever
having to think
about that stuff.
I wish nobody's kids
had to think about it.
Thanks again for inviting me.
I appreciate the time
to come and talk to you.